some states including california
michigan and new jersey will get
less of the coronavirus vaccines than
they expected new jersey health
officials say the state will get about
100 thousand
fewer doses of the pfizer and modern
vaccines than they planned on
the garden state reported more than 5
000 new coronavirus cases
just yesterday new jersey governor phil
murphy joins us now to talk about this
governor good to see you
good to see you vlad thanks for having
me so as we mentioned new jersey will
receive about 100
000 fewer doses than expected why is
that
listen you'll have to ask the feds that
they say it was an honest mistake in
their calculation i take that
on its face we're just going to keep our
heads down
and turn over every stone until we can
get everyone vaccinated i think we've
got
212 000 uh uh doses coming into the
state this week
between moderna and pfizer somewhat less
than we thought but we're going to use
every single one of them
so how will this impact the people who
need it most governor
well we're now in the 1a category the
health care workers and long-term care
residents and staff
that's those are our highest priorities
it'll probably honestly take a little
bit longer
to go through those entire communities
but we'll get there and we'll keep
scrapping
for every dose we can get so we expect
the first shots of the modern vaccine
to be administered as soon as today when
will new jersey get it
i think we're getting it today and uh in
fact i think we'll have
moderna here in new jersey if we don't
already it will be uh
we'll be uh administering those shots
uh very very soon so you mentioned the
federal government
uh are you satisfied with their guidance
on the distribution of vaccines
yeah i'm satisfied with their guidance
without question although
after you get through health care
workers and long-term care residents you
have a lot of populations
that are are rightfully vying to get
into that next
at the head of the line of the 1b group
essential workers
front line workers first responders
other vulnerable communities so
this is this is still a very satisfied
but let's all understand this is really
complex
and there's a lot of complexity still in
front of us
so what kind of resources could you use
to make the process a little smoother i
know you say that you're satisfied but
are there any additional resources
that you could use to ensure that people
in your state
have the vaccine when necessary yes
satisfied with the guidance
not yet satisfied with the resources we
need a lot more help
and i'm happy congress looks like
they're going to vote on this stimulus
bill
we'll take it we'll put it to good use
but it's a fraction of what we need
this is a this is a once in a century if
not
less frequent moment we need to meet
this moment
in size this does not pass that test
we'll take it
but we need a lot of federal help but
we're not alone this is every state
blue red every american state needs a
big jolt of
stimulus and help from the feds whether
it's administering vaccine
helping us with our budgets to keep
people employed uh small businesses
unemployed you name it
governor you've heard us reporting on
this new uh strain limitation of the
coronavirus vaccine that's been detected
in the united kingdom
new york governor andrew cuomo is asking
and calling on the federal government to
possibly
ban all air travel coming in from the uk
do you support a measure like that
listen his concerns are rightful based
on what we know we're still
investigating to be honest with you
we've got a bigger plea don't travel i i
frankly don't care where you're
traveling just don't travel
stay home stay small for the holidays
whether it's the uk or frankly any other
american state
the less travel we do right now the
smaller we celebrate and i know that
stinks to hear that
the faster we're gonna dig out of this
governor let me ask you about a
republican senator rick scott who
introduced a resolution which called out
some democratic governors including
yourself for infringing upon religious
freedoms by limiting capacity
at places of worship what's your
response to senator scott
that was ridiculous uh as usual senator
scott was completely wrong-headed
and i want to give a shout-out to my
friend one of our senators bob menendez
who made that point
crystal clear we want folks to worship
uh we want folks to exercise their faith
in fact we have i think quite
sensible regulations around our ability
to gather and we have
almost its moment one when we reopened
um
so i i rick scott i don't it's not even
worth talking about it he's wrong-headed
on this as he is
almost everything else i hear from him
all right governor filmer from new
jersey thank you very much sir have a
wonderful holiday and happy new year and
good luck with the vaccine distribution
same to you vlad thank you